hey everybody welcome to episode 8 of 13
o'clock tonight we're doing kind of a
geeky creepy kind of subject most of you
have probably heard of a serial killer
known as The Night Stalker Richard
Ramirez who was caught and actually died
in prison but what many people do not
know is that in the mid 70s to mid 80s
there was another serial killer and
rapist in California who was known as
the original Night Stalker
or he's sometimes also referred to as
the east area rapist yeah or the Golden
State killer yeah but this guy was the
original Night Stalker yes this happened
before the richard room because Richard
Ramirez was I think it was 85 86 the
this guy started in 1976 and the last
murder attributed him to 1986 now the
creepiest thing about this guy was that
they never caught him he's still out
there he's probably still out there
somewhere and he was worse than Richard
Ramirez well yeah he was a lot more
organized he was uh I think more deadly
he did more damage what was it 60 rapes
50 rape 50 rapes and murders 10 to 12
murders of murders now and he did
couples that was the weird part
yeah yeah he liked it if the guy was
there yeah he wanted him to watch and um
it's actually kind of timely that we're
doing this because when I was
researching the episode like I had
always kind of been interested in this
case anyway but when I was researching
the episode I saw that because June 2016
was the 40th anniversary of the first
crime the FBI is doing a big you know
like a new rollout of billboards and
they're offering a $50,000 reward for
new tips that lead to the identification
arrest and convict
of this person ya know when this
happened this kind of crossed my mind
that maybe the fbi's is thinking that
because he's kind of getting up there in
age he's probably at least 60 by now
that maybe he's in the mood to do a BTK
and step forward step for him and cash
in on his fame yeah
because he'd get pretty famous for this
[ __ ] they never caught this guy and he's
beasts he's a bad player yeah i player
and a lot of these I don't want to just
go out they want a bribe in the bank
that did kind of occur to me also
because it seems like and especially
this guy's particular mo um he didn't
really talk the police like in the way
say the Zodiac killer did but he did
call them and say where he was gonna be
and he so he did kind of play with them
a little bit he's up there with the
zodiac in terms of skill yeah he never
got caught no no and actually they never
even had any never had no suspects no
honestly no so I mean hit there such
thing as a serial killer role model and
be him and zodiac yeah and you never
hear much about the original Night
Stalker that's when they talk they talk
to that one away
and on the back shelf they forget about
the original nights well what actually
well I think why that happened was
because for a long time before the
advent of DNA testing um and because he
actually started out in the 70s as a
serial rapist yeah and then the murders
came later but it was like in another
town yeah and so since they didn't
really communicate back then the way
they do now they don't have like a
national database and all this other
kind of stuff so for a long time they
thought it was two separate guys Ron
until somebody went through the
cold-case and checked the DNA and then
found out that it was the same dude yeah
it was the same MO the same I guess you
could call the same tech that he used
it's just that it escalated to where he
killed the victims yeah and he got more
and more brutal as it went on yeah so
I'm gonna go ahead and tell the story
how does it start
okay well it started um in 1976 in
Sacramento
and the first things were a series of
rapes and these were the mo was pretty
much the same in everyone it was usually
a woman in a house alone the guy would
either find a window that was unlocked
or he would break in with a screwdriver
what have you in the middle of the night
and he would the woman would be sleeping
so he would sneak into her bedroom wake
her up without a light on her with a
flashlight in her face say he had a
knife or a gun then he would tie her up
and rape her he always wore a mask he
sometimes disguised his voice um but
none of the original rapists victims
really got a good look at him yeah and
he would stay in the house for hours
right yeah this is wood this was another
thing and actually I later on I'm like
maybe in a few minutes I'm gonna play
one of the women that was one of his
victims and it's about like a
three-minute clip of her talking about
the experience but and that's kind of
the most upsetting thing is because he
would come in their house he would tie
them up very tightly you know their arms
their ankles and lose circulation yeah
then he would rape them and then he
would wander around their house he would
dig through their [ __ ] he'd go eat food
out of their refrigerator sometimes he'd
come back and rape them again and um a
lot of the women said they they didn't
know like they were afraid to move or
try to escape because they didn't know
if he was still in the house or not
right and he was just yelling at him for
the most of the time it wasn't really
like torture per se like he wasn't
cutting anything off of amoreena it I
don't think so I don't think that was
ever reported right but um he really it
seemed like and even from the very
beginning it seemed like he was very
calculating like he would pick women who
were home by themselves or home and just
with small children right
the house would usually be by a creek or
a school or big open field or woods or
something like that where he could run
and hide and escape easily um he usually
knew the layout of the house so he broke
in there before he yes because sometimes
and usually neighbors had reported
prowlers there or there had been
break-ins in other houses in the
neighborhood almost as if he picked a
neighborhood and then he was casing the
place to look for the best victim
on some occasions he would like if a
house was for sale or something like
that but that people were still living
in it he would go in there and pose as
as a potential buyer so he could you
know check out the layout of the house
now this started in 1970s 1976 was the
first rape and there were I think there
ended up being I mean he ended up doing
at least 50 rapes and it was like only
in a three-year period I think when it
yeah from 1976 to 1979 and that's that's
a lot of stuff and he had a case each
one of those joints yeah he had to find
out said what when I was looking at the
list of crime scenes and victims mm-hmm
this guy it this had to be almost a
full-time job for him yeah it would have
had to have been because I mean the
dates of the rapes there's actually um
if you go there's a website I'll put a
I'll put a link in the in the
description its EA r - o NS com that
stands for East area rapist original
Nightstalker and they have a list of all
his crimes and the dates and the victim
and it seemed like the rapes I mean
there was one every couple of weeks yeah
which meant that I guess in those weeks
in between he was doing surveillance
right and breaking in beforehand getting
an idea the layout of the place he knew
these sometimes if the if the women had
guns in the house he would take the
bullets out of the guys unload he
load them and take the bullets so then
you know even if she did get to the gun
it would it would be empty
that makes me think that if he's in in
that neighborhood doing that
surveillance trying to find out where
they live and then coming up with a plan
on how to get in and out of there he
must have been this must been part of
his job he must have been something like
a mailman or a cop or something like
that it would have given him the ability
to go into those neighborhoods and not
be not be seen snooping around but the
only thing that really comes to mind
yeah what do you think and and it should
be because wouldn't you be at work
yeah we take a lot of time yeah you know
and you with it and it must be noted too
that all of the victims were quite
affluent these were nice guys
upper-middle to class just was upper
middle class neighborhoods always and so
it's kind of telling that he was never
really seen like no one reported anyone
suspicious they would see somebody with
a mask but that's when he was going to
but that's if she was going to do that I
think in the heel he worked in those
neighborhoods doing something a mailman
how would you how would you find these
women and where they live right you know
like you said it but I mean as many as
he did and this is just the first part
of his reign of terror this first
three-year period when he was just doing
the rapes as if that wasn't bad enough
right but um you know it got much worse
as we will get into but yeah like you
said I mean the amount of planning that
he went into this you didn't keep a
normal work schedule no you couldn't do
40 hours or 30 hours a week works you
know working it's a you know a coffee
shop or at a mechanic shop or anything
like that and half time to do that I'm
thinking he worked there yeah and doing
something well dave is a gardener but
they didn't they probably sure they were
to check that but I was thinking
something like a mailman because some of
the things that he did kind of had
paramilitary hint you know paramilitary
qualities to them a lot of times you
know I'm an ex-serviceman when you get
out of service you get get a job
offerings at the mail you know us man
yeah so maybe that's what he was doing
good mailman coz was it uh BTK was like
a dog catcher yeah it was like a dog so
I'm thinking I've tried a similar
situation a similar situation where he
wasn't somebody that would attract
attention
he was somebody official I think yeah
dog catcher mailman water meter reader
something like that and they did note
that he might have had a military
background because the ligatures that he
used to tie up the women and tie up the
victims was a very distinctive not a
diamond not yeah which is very difficult
yeah it's very difficult not to tie like
most people don't know how to do it and
somebody reported that he had a bulldog
tattooed on his form which of course
that's a symbol of you know US Marine
Marines yeah and they have a lot of
naval training this apartment of Navy
yeah so maybe he was next and there are
a lot of military bases around there
yeah maybe I maybe he was an ex-marine
and then he you know became a meter
reader or a mailman but I'm sure the
cops would have known that yeah you know
and check that it's just weird could be
that the report of him having a bulldog
tattoo on his forearm maybe that was a
fake tattoo yeah took up a lot o people
off would you know there's no no way
I've known is a long time ago yeah and
honestly um from all the rapes some some
women escaped without but you know like
I said he had weapons and yeah heat
security gun yeah he carried a gun and
he had a knife also and um
so actually what I'm gonna do now let me
I'm gonna play you this little bit it's
about three three and a half minutes
long of one of the victims while we're
still talking about the rapes so I'm
gonna play that for you right now it's
kind of upsetting but you know that's
our topic yeah here it is anyway
I woke up with a hand over my mouth and
I rolled out of bed ice this one lamb I
said what are you doing he was going
down the hall names just hitting me and
then I just pretended that he knocked me
outside quit hitting me and then I just
thought stuffed in my mouth blindfolded
gagged hands tied legs tied and then you
know hold me up like this because I was
on my stomach I can put me back in bed
and said if you move I'm gonna kill you
so you know yeah lay there for two hours
he came in I don't know I think five
different times or something like that
over the course of the night and raped
me
and well you're laying there thinking
you're gonna die you just are pretty
sure that you know I mean I remember
just kind of being in shock but I'm just
laying there on my stomach shivering
because I had a fever and you know how
you get the chills and shake and and so
um you know finally after I mean our
best guess is two hours it went on a
long time at about 4:30 in the morning I
had heard a car drive away and I started
counting to 60 because I didn't have any
concept of time so I counted to 63 times
then figured then a half hour would have
gone by with no noise in the house and I
got up didn't know if he was there
I used to say and I'm sure that you know
who knows that we I remember saying when
it was still going on if they ever catch
this guy
they should lay him on the floor and let
everybody that he raped get to do
whatever they want him you know I just
thought that's what we should get to do
and then a thought kind of went away but
I thought you know we should get to do
what we want you know we had to go
through this
I don't think that I would need to hurt
him
you know if I if he was caught I don't
need to get any revenge I don't need
anything like that I I just liked it
there to be closure but I have to say
you know there hasn't it felt pretty
close to me for a long time I do not I'm
always aware of anybody coming up behind
me and it's not a fear I don't have a
fear with that I'm just aware I'll look
over my shoulder all the time and you
know it's just the way that came out of
it but that's my guess you know my
rationalization that I can do all these
things because I'm super aware of what's
going on
I have to do a lot of self-talk when my
husband's away for the weekend I have to
tell myself that there's so many next
door that's a single woman that stays
home every night by herself and she
hasn't yet I mean I have to do this all
every time he goes away and he doesn't
go away very much maybe at the most once
a year but I don't just peacefully go to
sleep every night okay so um so
evidently that's what it was like yeah
for most people at least yeah and
another thing that he did while he was
still on the rape kick and this is still
in the Sacramento area was he would
sometimes call the person who was going
to be his victim he would either call
them beforehand um and he would say it
was a wrong number or he would just hang
up check and see if they're there
checking to see if they're there um a
couple times he threatened them
beforehand now ya see it's not real
clear like sometimes he would come in to
rape the women blah blah and then like a
day or two later they would get a phone
call he call her back and he'd call her
back threatening to kill her and I
actually and actually right now but I
have audio of one
okay he's like disguising his voice yeah
but yet this is pretty creepy okay check
this out
yeah uh-huh
so um terror tactics yeah he's trying to
victimize her a second time yeah yeah
don't forget about me you know that's
that's yeah it was that guy still got
you that kind of mentality and he also
they allegedly they think that he called
the cops a few times too and said where
he was going to strike hmm like I'm
gonna strike on
I think Watts Avenue or something like
that good boss on this day or so did and
he did now he didn't um actually rape
anyone that night but they saw a guy on
that street with a hood with a mask
riding a bicycle and and most of the
witnesses that said like that think that
he that he would drive to somewhere near
the site and then he would ride a bike
yeah to the action he had a stolen
bicycles that he'd carry with him and
that he'd discard him when he was done
with him yeah so and it's weird too
because a lot of Bailey in his license
plate yeah well in the world things I
was damaged approach yeah when there
were suspicious vehicles reported it was
almost always different vehicles like I
think the only one that was reported in
more than one case was a VW Bug shades
at Ted Bundy yeah although I think it
was a gray or green with the wide wheels
people also reported a white Pontiac
there were several other cars so they
don't know if the guy had access to a
bunch of different cars he was stealing
cars right you know what well I wouldn't
make sense of steal a car that's just
additional heat that's what I made
illegal in taxes and I didn't see
anything that you know said that there
were stolen cars or anything like that
so basically he did he was a rapist now
they think from his profile that he
probably started just as a burglar right
I mean the FBI like I was watching
earlier if you look on YouTube there is
a FBI press conference from June 2016
where they're kind of you know
summarizing the case and talking about
how they're trying to you know generate
new tip
so whatnot and he said that they that
aside from all the other crimes this guy
committed they also want him for a
hundred and twenty five burglaries
yeah but was he actually stealing
anything of value during the problem he
would just take kind of not super
valuable [ __ ] that's not really a
burglar hey yeah don't that take
that's a peeping tom yeah that's gone
he's been peeping through windows and
then he's in the side he's gonna go in
there and violate that space maybe take
somebody socks or underwear so he could
sniff I'm something like crazy oh yeah
and then it knitties watching then later
on he's watching women through the
windows yeah and then it escalates imma
going there to get one yeah that's
that's what he did what not a burglar no
he must have money what yeah they
thought right away to walk away from the
valuables because he did yeah if you
think the most valuable thing he took he
would take like costume jewelry which
isn't really worth much of just Joe fees
or he would take like coins he
particularly liked coins for some reason
like collectible coins collectible coins
yeah he would take some of those weird
so um in one case he actually they found
the woman's TV in her backyard like he
had started to take it but left it like
he was trying to make it look like a
botched robbery or what-have-you
he had money yeah he must have yeah
because he everyone the movie yeah I
don't think he ever took any money or
anything like that um like he said he
just took clothes I think he took
driver's licenses [ __ ] like that that's
so that's so you could threaten him
later right they know that you know the
victims know that he has their ID yeah
so that's kind of like I own you yeah I
know where you live I know I live I know
your name yeah that's a that's a
psychological ploy there yeah so
baselessly also an easy way to remember
the victim it's a trophy well yeah yeah
and actually I was watching another
because I kind of went off on the true
crime thing today after I started
watching that so I started watching all
these other crime once too and that is a
very common it's a trope
it's very common of serial offenders of
keeping people's IDs and clothes and
things like that so basically from 1976
to 1979 there were I think
like I said about 50 rapes right in and
around the Sacramento area now at this
point things took kind of a horrible
turn in 19th February of 1978 there was
a married couple called the Majoris they
were minding their own business they
were out walking their dog a man
approached them and some kind of
altercation ensued um
which they don't really give you the
details about that yeah I don't really
know some like I don't know why the guy
like just walked up to him I don't know
the police don't want the public to know
what the nature of the altercation was
yeah maybe not but as it but as it was
the guy yeah the guy pulled a gun um
the couple turned and ran um and the guy
chased them yeah he tracked down the man
first shot him point blank in the chest
killed him yeah and the woman kept
running and she was running through
people's backyards it such a bad ances
jumped fences and stuff and then finally
she got boxed in and he came and shot
her in the face
shattered face and she died also didn't
want any uh any witnesses to survive
yeah yeah and um say and then the
neighbors saw that he just ran right the
neighbors saw some of that remember they
interviewed a guy that yes that's right
he saw the guy running off and he let
that and he saw he saw the witness who
saw the shooting he let that witness
live yeah
never then yeah that's right that go
ahead kid yeah they yeah they
interviewed a guy who had seen some of
the some of it and uh he said the guy
looked at him yeah so side note the the
community was so terrified on one
occasion a woman saw him with a mask
going behind another house and she was
too afraid to even call the police she
just let that person get raped that and
that yeah she should have been charged
yeah you know all she had it let me go
look I understand you're scared but it's
like he doesn't he didn't see her he
didn't see her it's you know yeah that's
good I mean help us
every Mon you know you need to do time
just for cowardice let people get raped
and die that way man yeah that's awful
no so game on you whoever you are
yeah yeah yeah we don't know who that
was it was just somebody that lived
across from one of the victims but it
would seem that this kind of seemingly
random murder of this couple was kind of
like that was almost kind of like the
when he graduated from just like rapes
two murders then it's almost like the
raping wasn't enough of a challenge
anymore
he had he had to up it he had up the
ante you know and what ended up
happening after that I think there were
actually a few more rapes after the
Majoris were murdered but these rapes
took place when the woman's husband was
in the house right maybe he got a taste
for dominating a couple yeah and he
wanted the kingdom and two witnesses
right what do you previously - that he
would target women in the house alone
teenage girls in the house alone or
women just with small children right it
seems like after the Majoris were
murdered um he decided well I I want to
kind of up the ante so what he would do
now was he would specifically target a
woman at a man usually husband a wife or
boyfriend and girlfriend in the house
and he would go same kind of thing he
would he would break into the house
beforehand unload their guns you know
leave a window open let's see what I
think happened with the first two slangs
the ones that were done in public
outside yeah
those weren't planned no of course not
so he killed two people and got out of
there yeah and I gave him a huge
endorphin rush yeah and that became part
of his MO is if you know what I'm gonna
do that again yeah I'm gonna do that
again I liked how that felt yeah it's
that's that's what happened there see he
kind of stumbled into the murder thing
yeah just added that to the rape and
robbery and home invasion yeah
there were actually a few cases where he
would you know he would break into the
house a few days before it was under
surveillance
Rico house he'd recon the house and then
finally he would break in while the
couple were sleeping yeah shine a light
in their face hold a gun in their face
he would make the woman tie the man up
yeah tightly anytime then he would tie
up the woman and then he would retie the
man Taylor yeah um and then on many
occasions then he would take the woman
into another room not in the living room
yeah out in the living room now
sometimes some people that lived
reported that he would go get dishes out
of their cupboard and put them like he
the man would be facedown its died on
its back they would stack him on his
back and he said if I hear these
rattling I'm killing her right yeah so
and that's because the very first one
that he did the two got away that's
right okay so to prevent that from
happening he started stacking dishes on
the man so if he moved yeah he'd hear it
that's right the first the first one he
did like that he actually watched it
yeah they got away um he went in there
he did his tying up thing the woman like
he went back down the the killer went
down the hall to check on the dude and
she got up and she hopped up to her feet
I mean her feet into her ankles were
tied but she got to her feet and she
hopped out the door into the front yard
and started screaming not the first time
second time yeah he grabbed she hopped
that when she she got up hopped out he
grabbed her drugged her back in went to
check on the guy yeah cuz the guy was I
think the guy was getting out he's
trying to get out of hand he was trying
to get out of the house he got him to
lay back down and during that time that
woman had gone right back out the front
door again and started screaming yeah so
he runs and jumps on his bike he
realized he's lost control situation he
jumps on his bike and what it yes she
was out in the front yard screamin and
it happened that their neighbor was an
FBI agent right he heard and he heard
her screaming so he came he called for
backup and came out to see what was
going on saw the guy get on the bike and
roll he saw the guy get on Easter and he
chased him in his car but he couldn't
catch him me whatever the
and then a guy dumped the bike and ran
into the woods yeah and got away yeah so
um and I don't think they didn't see his
face though did that and I was running a
mask yeah I mean he that he wore a ski
mask pretty much all the time
they do have composite sketches of him
but all of them look different one of
them looks just like Ted Cruz smells
good I know Ted Cruz in serial killers
man they said he looked like the the
Zodiac killer but he looks like the
original Night Stalker also yeah it's
but well especially like the original
Night Stalker that one of the newer
sketches that they have that
[ __ ] smirk yeah well they said
he acted really superior yeah or an
arrogant and uh you know description
they think I mean he's white dude uh not
sucked in about five ten not fat at kind
of athletic build they said he was in
good physical shape uh brown or dirty
blond hair yeah started at new pry in
his late teens early 20s yeah they think
he was probably in his early 20s when he
started blue or hazel eyes size 9 shoe
he usually wore tennis shoes or combat
boots yeah he kind of had a little
superhero outfit too one of the drawings
look like a tight wetsuit with a belt on
and a gun and a bat antenna and uh
looked like a utility pouch on the other
side yeah and his uh his little bonus
isn't yeah because he was wearing short
sleeves with Bulldog tattoo and he had
his ski mask on uh not quite as scary as
the zodiac killers outfit but pretty
intimidating I guess yes I like I would
think kind of like looked kind of like
daredevil yeah yeah yeah okay so here
was the weird thing though there was a
gap of I think it was three months I
want to say and the rapes stopped in the
Sacramento area now later on all of
these similar kind of things started
happening in where in Southern
California right yeah
so the funny thing was that at first
they thought the east area rapist and
then all these murders started happening
in Southern California like it like 300
miles away and they thought it was two
separate dudes like you know this was
back this was 70s and 80s and you know
like I said they didn't have the same
communication that they would have
nowadays
yeah they ended up linking the two
clusters of crimes together but DNA the
rapes a number yeah but that didn't
happen until 1996 later
yeah I'm up until then they thought the
east area rapist at the original Night
Stalker to the murderer were two
different guys and okay we're coming up
on the half-hour mark so I'm going to
take our first break and then we will be
right back I would like to take a second
and thank subculture corsets in clothing
for sponsoring project I radio and my
show while listening to my podcast
please take a second and visit their
website at www.att.com/biz gothic
steampunk and pinup clothing shoes and
accessories again their website is
subculture corsets calm or if you're in
the jacksonville florida area stop by
their store in The Avenues Mall and if
you like to save money use the discount
code 13 o'clock when checking out and
save 10% off your entire order by the
way if you're a curvy girl subculture do
not forget about you they carry size 4
to 4 X and guys they have men's clothing
and shoes as well so go shop at
subculture corsets calm now and use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount ok and we're back original
night's talk the original Night Stalker
and the reason that he ended up having
that name like I said was because
because they didn't know that this was
the same dude run you know Richard
Ramirez was called the Night Stalker in
the 80s and then they found out this guy
was this rapist and murderer who had
done all this [ __ ] he was like worse
yeah so you know they'd had to call him
the original night star he doesn't
really have his
name I've seen him called the Golden
State killer I've seen him called the
diamond not killer because of that not
that he would tie but um Richard Ramirez
Night Stalker paled in comparison to the
original nice but he did yeah this dude
was yeah he had his [ __ ] together and
like I said he never got caught they
still don't know they still don't know
who he is I don't even think they had
any like I said they don't think they
really had any suspects
you know Ramirez was like a cheap
knockoff really of the original Night
Stalker yeah no I don't think Richard
made it where Ramirez he can knew who
the original Night Stalker was yeah I
don't think he was aware of this case no
no which is really weird cuz like I said
that you know they didn't link them
until 1996 when they when somebody was
researching the cold case - I think
Ramirez he was dead by 96 would be when
did he die
I don't know that someone he just died
in prison like Iran he was 53 I think I
don't risen for a while I doubt Ramirez
was aware of this guy
probably not Yona been ever have been a
big blow to his ego probably yeah
but the case we were talking about just
now where the people got away that was
it actually in 1979 now that happened in
Goleta which is what I think it I'm not
from California you are but that's
that's about 300 miles from Sacramento
right south of Sacramento cries someone
go something like that okay so so those
two escaped they lived now that was in
October of 1979 in at the end of
December
another couple had the same thing
happened except they were not as lucky
as the first couple that is they were
both killed now this was it was actually
a dr. dr. Robert Offerman was the guy's
name and Deborah Alexander Manning I
think she was a doctor as well or a
psychologist and they were actually
found shot that was another thing that
this guy I mean he he did pretty much
the same thing with the ligatures and
the you know similar kind of MO some of
the victims were shot most of them were
bludgeoned to death yeah I think one
time you used a log did he log from the
fireplace yeah
and some of it was overkill I mean just
like smashing the faces in and stuff
yeah that they think that he had a
really for some reason he had a very
very intense hatred of women huh because
he just went off yeah I mean he would
just crush their skulls and crush their
faces and you know the cops that were
interviewed they just said it was the
most horrible nah you know scene you'd
ever want to say but um but this this
first couple that were they were also in
galleta it was a doctor and like I said
I believe me Debra Manning was a
psychologist if I'm not mistaken now
these two were shot um but what they
think ended up happening he did tie them
up but the man's bindings were untied so
they think that he might have lunged at
the guy run and then the guy like kind
of lost control and he shot both and
he'd shot him both and they said that
neighbors heard the gunshots but thought
it was just fireworks or something so
they didn't report anything on this
particular case never mention what
caliber that was um they have it was
three different calibers that he used
one was a 38 when was 357 and I don't
remember what the other one was but um
cuz it in the reenactments a lot of
times they showed a little like a small
automatic like a little 380 I didn't
know if he said that he was using more
than one yeah okay yeah and like I said
in a lot of the cases he bludgeoned the
people the death sometimes with stuff
that was in the house like so he didn't
bring anything with him on this
particular murder the Offerman and
Manning murders they found footprints
from a dog paw prints so they think he
might have brought a dog with him weird
he went in their refrigerator and there
was leftover Christmas turkey in there
it was five days after Christmas and
they think that he fed some of the
turkey to the doc Wow wonder why he'd
bring his dog yeah maybe that was his
cover walking a dog yeah could be maybe
could be so that was 1979 so those were
his two couple murders now then in 1980
March of
nineteen eighty another couple was found
murdered in Ventura and these were this
was the this was the log bludgeoning but
he had tied them both up he raped the
woman and then he took a log from their
fireplace and beat them to death this
was also the you know they found the
same knot he then he tied them with
drapery cord and then that was in March
of nineteen eighty and then there was
another one in um August of 1980 and
that's in that was in Dana Point
California which I think was a few miles
south of Ventura and this was actually
kind of a sad one because they were so
young it was a Keith Harrington and
Patrice Harrington keith was 24 he was a
medical student and Patrice was 27 she
was a nurse and they had been married
three months terrible and Patrice was
raped of course they had both been tied
up although they didn't find the
ligatures this time and they didn't find
the murder weapon this time I'm not sure
if they were yeah I guess they were
legend he couldn't be kind of loose and
just took all that stuff with him for
some reason yeah yeah not sure why maybe
wanted to make it look like he changed
his MO something like that yeah because
that was another thing then whatever
they reported in the media it was almost
like if they said you know in the paper
that he didn't do this at the thing or
he would then he would do that at the
next crime scene so he was obviously
following the media coverage as most
serial killers do yeah and tell about
the story of the guy at the meeting oh
yeah okay [ __ ] and actually I don't
think they set us on the Wikipedia page
but we were watching um we were watching
a documentary about it and they
mentioned this they said you know
obviously this might have been I don't
know if this was in Sacramento or if
this was in the other other areas matter
but it doesn't really matter so they had
had this big meeting in the community
because of you know obviously everyone
was freaking out and everyone was scared
yeah they wanted to ask law
questions yeah they wanted to ask the
sheriff so I was like why haven't you
caught this guy bloody blah yeah so this
one guy stands up and says I don't see
how this could happen like how could a
guy just come into your house and just
rape your wife and you not do anything
about it and blah-dee-blah right and
then shortly afterward the guy broke
into his house and did that exact thing
he tied the guy up he tied the woman up
be raped her
did he kill the guy no okay I don't
think I think this was before he had
started the murdering so it must have
been yeah that must have been he took
that as a challenge he says okay I'll
show you how how it happened yeah and it
is there and he was there in the crowd
so they think that maybe he was at that
meeting now you were saying before that
how would he have tracked that guy down
I mean did the guy stand up and go I'm
such-and-such from this address you know
probably not yeah okay cuz he couldn't
go up and talk to the guy yeah the guy
might recognize him at the crime scene
yeah he couldn't follow him home because
that guy might figure out he's being
followed so he probably just watched
what car he walked into and got that
license plate and then tracked him down
by that license plate which would lead
me to suspect with that back in those
days that would be hard to do I think
maybe only a cop could do that yeah or
someone who had access to and there was
speculation that he might be a cop kind
of balls he had and the things that he
was doing that think the things that he
was doing man sounds kind of cop like
yeah I mean he was in those
neighborhoods for long periods of time
scoping out these women trying to a get
out when he should be somewhere working
right maybe that was his job maybe he
was a cop yeah um it would explain a lot
but I'm sure they thought of that yeah
you would think you would think they
would be smart enough to come to
conclusion hey this might be a cop yeah
who patrols this area you know is there
anything in common between that area and
this area over here right was there a
cop that worked over in that part of
town
is he now working in this part of town
that kind of thing yeah evidently there
was no connection yeah I guess not but
like you said it does seem very maybe he
was a cop at one point would have had to
have access to the to the
to the I guess the equipment you would
need back in the 70s to try it out a
license plate now how it was done back
then now you could do it pretty easily
well yeah you can find it you can find
anybody now and not the 70s no [ __ ] they
didn't even like I said they didn't even
know this was the same dude you could
probably track down a license plate in
the 70s but you'd probably make a paper
trail trip tracking it yeah I pride to
go to the DMV and said who is this who
is that yeah yeah they probably tell you
but like you said there'd be a record of
your record but um maybe he did maybe
I'm just underestimated maybe he just
followed that dude home yeah and the guy
didn't notice it didn't notice it yeah I
mean he seems a risk though yeah but he
did take risks this guy original Night
Stalker took a lot of risks yeah
breaking into a house once and then
setting it up for an invasion unloading
the guns yeah
leaving a loophole in the security like
taking screens off yeah and then coming
back just a day later yeah and like I
said on a few occasions you know he
posed as a perfective buyer of the house
so people I mean you must have seen his
face yeah he's not gonna wear a mask in
there hey I'm gonna buy the house that's
a ballsy move that's very risky yeah
somebody could remember his face yeah
what if somebody who knew him saw him
yeah that house hey what are you doing
here where you gonna buy this house man
yeah that's what I'm very risky but um
maybe he wasn't rational maybe wouldn't
think about it just did it yeah I'm
gonna go in there you just act like I'm
gonna buy this house yeah sometimes you
know being stupid is quite smart yeah
you know I'm gonna leave my bicycle here
on the front porch it's broad daylight
no one would steal this go in come out
it's gone yeah that guy's an awful dumb
steal this thing in broad daylight
well shady got your bicycle hub could've
been that I had a bicycle stolen in
broad daylight yeah I've had a bicycle
stolen burnt but um okay so there were
actually uh more murders in what is it
time for a second break not yet okay
I went sold with maybe like another five
minutes all right he's like poking at me
go go go Ababa no okay we just did one
it's all right all right
well doing it like 45 minutes all right
all right so uh 1981
uh February 6th uh this woman her name
is Manuela wit Hyun she was 28 years old
also raped and murdered now she was
alone in her house at the time although
she was married but her husband happened
to be in the hospital yeah recovering
from an illness and she had just come
back from the hospital visiting him yeah
and you know she came back home and she
got raped and murdered nice daughter got
her yeah so I don't know if he had
actually planned for the guy to be in
there and the need wasn't there or if he
was going back to his hey woman alone
type [ __ ] because it seemed like maybe
he'd planned for the guy to be there
that's what I was thinking because all
the other ones were couple murders she
was the only in the you know in this in
the later stay in the in this later
stage but um you know again she was
bludgeoned to death
they found she had been tied up but no
ligatures found out murder weapon and
this was the one whose TB was found in
the backyard and he did actually take a
lamp from her house yeah one oh what a
lamp and a crystal curio when I got out
of there carrying a lamp without
attracting attention yeah what kind of
lamp are we talking about is it like a
big huge light and a crystal curia like
a curio yeah not a curio cabinet right
like just maybe like a crystal doohickey
like a bell or something so they want to
take that that looked good in my place
that's weird
that is weird yeah I don't know and then
in July 81 there was another couple
murder
Gregory Sanchez and his girlfriend Sheri
Domingo and these were the tenth and
eleventh victims and this was also in
Goleta which it was actually a few
blocks from one of the first couple
marks where the doctors were murdered
and yeah that's the weird thing
he killed some people in one house or
raped some people in one house and then
a couple weeks later raped raped some
people in a house just like a half a
mile away yeah or a quarter mile away or
the same blossom block yeah yeah like
you said ballsy yeah I'm gonna come back
and get that one yeah you know now after
Sheri Domingo and Gregory Sanchez were
killed this was in 1981
one then there was a gap of five years
where no murders or rapes of that MO
happened in either area five years
that's like two military enlistments
maybe yeah or you know they they say
thank you later you might have been
incarcerated for something else I doubt
it yeah I doubt it I think if you that
guy ever fell into custody he would be
suspicious of him yes he'd get caught
doing something that's kind of related
like cat burglary or yeah peeping tom
type stuff did go into his house
probably and say hey what's that lamp
doing there you know hey I have a study
that lamp looks yeah that looks familiar
I don't I think he had money he didn't
he wasn't stealing anything so he wasn't
living off of the commission of crime
now he had a regular job yeah and where
he had a rich family something like that
I was kind of thinking that actually
yeah he might have inherited a bunch of
money and he didn't work yeah if he
defeat you know if he didn't work in
those communities then he didn't need to
work yeah I couldn't run a full-time job
doing what doing what he was doing yeah
there's no way how would he have time he
wouldn't have time no so so the after
like I said after sherry Domingo and
Gregory Sanchez were killed then there
was a five-year gap it stopped but then
in 1986 in May a girl named Janelle Cruz
who was only 18 years old found raped
and bludgeoned in Irvine her mother was
in Mexico on vacation yeah I saw and
they showed him both they were both real
good-looking women yeah
and Janelle had been left by herself now
originally Janelle Janelle's murder they
thought that it was maybe her boyfriend
or her little friend who had been
because he had been over at the house
like the night didn't want to say he was
over and he didn't want to say that he
was over there you know maybe you know
maybe mom didn't appear driving or
something like that but you know he had
a girlfriend yeah or that date oh my
goodness or that too but it was quickly
determined from you know later from DNA
and simply doesn't know that it wasn't
him that she was the last wanna and
that was the last one that they know of
1986 Janelle Cruz she was the last one
and she was bludgeoned to death with a
pipe wrench
I believe Wow and her mother said that
her face and head was just crushed yeah
he first hit her from the back and then
he just went off yeah and she said she
said that he hit her in the back of the
head while she was walking away from him
so she must have not have been tied down
yeah I was I kind of wondered about that
yeah I mean that was her mom talking so
maybe she didn't know maybe she didn't
know but um yeah so so at that point
like I said in the 80s they didn't know
that this was they thought this was two
separate guys no in 1996 of someone was
going through some of the Cold Case
Files and came across some of the [ __ ]
and said hey I'm gonna check the DNA on
this and that the other thing and it
turned out and actually at the time
there was like a couple investigators
that suspected that maybe this was the
same dude but most of most of the
investigators are like nods on the same
design even though the mo was very
similar but when they did the DNA they
found yes the east area rapist and the
original light sucker Golden State
killer whatever that was happening in
Irvine or whatever same was the same guy
which means that in total this man was
responsible for at least 50 rapes and 12
murders at least that they know of right
which makes him one of the most prolific
they said one of the most prolific
serial offenders in history yeah
California history US history I bet
there's more
oh I'm sure but they're usually I bet
you can't little side gigs they I'll
never know about yeah he might have been
also picking up hookers and killing them
ya know
right yeah and the only reason these
ones got a best cause these were all
kind of what my middle class maybe he
killed weathers a different way yeah or
the bodies that were never found
something like that it wasn't surprising
right all right so um right now I'm
gonna take our second break Glendale and
then
and they will kind of come back and wrap
the stuff up yeah and that's how we do
so here's the second break enjoy there's
hair is real and imaginary and I write
about them all paranormal non fiction
horror fiction the mammoth is the stable
monster Red Menace the patina gray cell
whether go to WWJD Ashbrook calm or
search amazon for the Jenny Ashford
author page okay now another interesting
aspect of this case and they talked
about this a little bit in one of the
documentaries we saw about it was that
they wondered because the rapes and
murders stopped in 1986 and they didn't
find there were no further crimes that
match that MO so they wondered if
perhaps he had been incarcerated for
something else so what they did was they
wanted to they kind of went through the
California penal system and they tried
to find dudes who were out at that
particular time period who had committed
the similar types of crimes the human
that kind of same description same
description same age whatnot and they
wanted to collect DNA samples because at
this point they had DNA samples of the
guy yeah they just didn't have anything
to compare it to right so they found one
dude that was in prison he was on death
row I believe for something else and he
kind of matched the you know the profile
of what they were looking for and they
so they asked for some blood so they
could get some DNA and he said no of
course he knows it now apparently in
California at the time the law was they
couldn't force the inmates to give blood
well he's on death row he said no
because he wanted some cookies and he
wanted a case of soda delivery you know
he's going to give it up for free and I
want cookie yeah you're gonna have to
bring me something you know you want
something for me you know you gotta give
him right that's probably what happened
that so actually that so that inmates
saying no to giving blood actually led
to one of the victims brother
years had a lot of money and he put
about two million bucks into backing a
law that would make it so that they
could use quote-unquote reasonable force
to take DNA samples from inmates yeah so
um that ended up passing they did
collect samples from all of these guys
but found nothing yeah he wasn't him so
at this point so the guy who said no was
just doing it to be a dick yeah he's not
really the killer he's just like I just
don't want to do it with you you know
the blood the man's not taking my blood
but um so at this point like I said
fortieth anniversary of the first rape
yeah they still have no idea who this
dude is yeah there were no suspects no
nothing now there are if you go on the
FBI website they have like a little you
know they have like a little section
about it that kind of gives a rundown of
the case and what you know what they
know about him which isn't a lot they
have some sketches but like I said they
all look kind different yeah and he just
looks like one look a dude he just looks
like one looks like flat the 1970 splash
or the 1980 splash chord yeah the other
one looks like Ted Cruz yeah and the
other one looks like Donald Duck yeah
it's like he just looks like a regular
guy he's just a regular white guy it was
kind of described just kind of like a
middle class or upper middle class white
guy yeah and they've also done um you
know they've had their you know serial
killer profilers and they're doing a
psychological profile they actually
think they think if anybody knows this
guy they're like he's a dick in life he
arrogant superior um prized use of
probably abusive controlling they're
actually kind of hoping that they said
now if he's doing this [ __ ] to these
women then he's probably doing it to any
consensual partners as well yeah he's a
wife beater right so
they kind of want to find either
prostitutes or women who might have been
in a consensual relationship with him um
you know although that's just theory yes
is he ready to hear me TK was a dick but
he wasn't a dick to his wife yeah all
right
but he was a real dick to his victims
they just [ __ ] everybody else's job is
to be a dick yeah he was finding people
for having their lawns a little bit too
long and not housing their dogs
correctly and you know yeah it was a
stickler yeah he got off on that little
petty control kind of [ __ ] run so II
might I think he's gonna be a guy a lot
like BTK yeah I kind of get the
impression that he's probably that kind
of a dude yeah like he's he really likes
having control total control over a
situation he had a minor official
position in something somewhere yeah I'm
talking about yeah mail mailman dog
catcher yeah something like that like
you said what you like BTK they they
want to have control but they're really
not they're not all that power yeah
they're kind of you know I mean bill TK
was kind of yeah he was kind of a loser
yeah sorta well you know dog catchers
you know like garbage man that's I
wouldn't called losers they make money
yeah but they're not as powerful to say
like a senator or an emperor right
president you know they you know they
want to be an emperor
yeah be a king yeah you know that's what
they want to be but that's kind of what
this dude sounds like from the
psychological profile that's probably
what this dude is like he's not dead
he's still out there
yeah that's not saying much yeah you
know he would probably be I mean
depending on how old he was
if say he was 25 when he committed the
first rapes then he would be 65 now yeah
he's probably out there he could be
somebody's grandpa I predict that I
predicted he'll come forward if he's
alive if you didn't you know die from
disease or die by an accident earlier on
he'll probably come forward do it
deathbed confession to cash in on all
his rep points think about it yeah and
then he can revitalize everybody yeah
then he can yeah I did that [ __ ] yeah
they like that yeah I'm gonna go out
with a bang you know I can I can see
that yeah you'll probably you're
probably hear from him yeah
but um just look at it if you're let's
say you're dying you're getting old yeah
okay maybe you don't have a whole lot to
look forward to in terms of time why
would you just waste away in obscurity
when you could reclaim that spotlight
yeah and say yeah that was me that shows
and just like BTK did even though you
could say that BTK didn't really just
come forward and confess the stuff that
BTK did will get you caught
yeah he did it all so he's gotta get it
on purpose yes like without being
without being realized now I mean this
guy original lights talker he did do
some of that kind of [ __ ] like he sent a
poem to the Sacramento Bee edge idli
allegedly we don't know that's really
you know they found some like maps and
stuff allegedly that he had drawn of you
know his stakeout areas and things like
that but then again I could be wrong
because you know zodiac never came
forward
true but zodiac could have gotten killed
doesn't yeah I mean that's what I mean
and that could have happened to this guy
- it's like yeah they you know who's to
say that he didn't break into somebody's
house and they shot his ass yeah yeah
and they didn't call the cops and they
didn't call the cops or they captured
him yeah that would be worst-case
scenario for him yeah he's written
they're raping two dudes wife and that
dude gets free yeah captures that guy um
and he [ __ ] they tortured him to
death yeah okay well they're not gonna
call the cops
no no especially if they know who it is
was it well they do that's what I mean
they would know I mean they would know
that that was that guy oh yeah
well sure cuz yeah MO and everybody in
those areas knew knew that this was
going on right and there may have been
one bad ass out there saying well what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put a blade
underneath my bed so I could roll off
the bed and cut my yeah cut these
literature's yeah and then I'm gonna
grab this hidden weapon I'm gonna come
out and I'm gonna capture him and I'm
gonna make sure that I'm gonna torture
that dude to death yeah that may have
happened to him yeah there's always a
bigger fish oh yeah and you know just
because you're not out there killing all
these people doesn't mean that you know
there isn't some hidden badass out there
going yeah come in this house I'm gonna
do them
I'm gonna get you mmm that may have
happened yeah could have cuz you know
you might have some guys saying the well
if the cops get him justice will not be
done yeah cuz they'll just lock him up
I'm gonna bring justice to this guy yeah
you know yeah they might have killed him
over a period of days you don't know
yeah you know so so we don't know we
don't know but if he is still alive he'd
be kind of an old man now not time to
step forward yeah why not FBI is
offering $50,000 for any information
looking for new tips anybody that might
remember him remember something they saw
back then and I'll probably put all
those links in there and whatnot yeah
but we're probably coming up I took a
second break dinner yeah he took a break
we could wrap it up I don't even
remember him since I am but uh you know
we went we went through Hurricane
Matthew yeah you know we're little and
it wasn't even that bad where we were
you know went without power for a while
I had to run the generator it wasn't
running right yeah kind of sucked we
don't want to bore him with all that
though yeah but you know it was a lot
worse for other people but yet it kind
of suck we have not much sleep that's
why we're kind of rambling but uh so
anyway I hope you enjoyed the show on
the original Night Stalker and as always
if you like the show please subscribe to
our channel or check us out on Twitter
or Facebook or whatever and I probably
believe will put the little screen up
there with all that [ __ ] on there and
next time it won't be tired yeah I think
we did okay though yeah for being tired
we did we did all right
yeah mumbling a little bit that's okay
I'll give it you can mobile I kept my
eyes open until now now they're yeah
they're closed and now they're closed
sir okay all right thanks for listening
bye
you